[Music]
more bad courage bad from break as well
as just a tandem here on the Richardson
show good to see you Jeff great to see
you my friend
Wednesdays at 8:00 eastern time 60s and
the Goldbergs currently on ABC yep and
your bears are absolutely a dream come
true I think this year correct hi honey
you're playing with house money right
now we truly are I'll tell you why
because I came on the show and I told
you if they went eight and eight yes I
thought it would be a great year so Mr
Mac though has changed things he has has
he not one man changed the whole
environment Jon Gruden I feel bad you
mentioned I went to the game with
Anthony Anderson
he's a Raiders fan he knows Kali Mac and
he he's not pleased well I'll tell you
what man what the Bears have done this
year has really been impressive because
sometimes you get the sense well you
could see this something forming but
this is not the year you know this could
truly be one for the ages and I don't
want for the ages why not why can't if
we saw what Kurt Warner was able to do
in year one and what Brady there's our
weakness and that's it what is their
weakness you the kicking you're the
field goal and a point after okay it
every time he goes behind there you're
like what's gonna happen that's party
right is a Cody Cody parking okay so I'm
surprised he's even still on the team
but that shows you there's nobody out
there so you don't consider true Biscay
potentially a liability because never
before oh no playoffs that kid as calm
as can be he's fantastic and the one
thing that I think now in the modern
game that you have to do as a
quarterback is be able to avoid a sack
and that dude is as good as they come as
I've ever seen at avoiding sex when
chase Daniels is in there for the two
weeks yes the minute there was any
pressure you just went plays dead plays
over you know if they gave chase Daniel
time he's good enough II he had
all these great passes but the second
any pressure trip its king he gets away
from it I don't know what the
percentages are but I'm guessing over
90% well that's why you need to have
somebody like Khalil Mack on your team
for four to flip that script to make
sure that you provide the pressure on
your opponent and it's ridiculous what
was it like being in that building on on
Sunday being in Soldier Field because
let me just let me set it up here okay
because speaking as a Michigan Wolverine
right this was a year Michigan was
supposed to beat Ohio State expected to
beat Ohio State and if they beaten how
Ohio State it not only would have stuck
it to Ohio State and Urban Meyer but it
also would have put Michigan into the
national champion champion ship
conversation so so much was at stake and
then it was a total yes the buckle I'm
wondering if there was what it was like
having those steaks well I'm always a
person when I watch sports I I have
great respect for a puzzle guy I have
great respect for the Packers even
though they're having an off year and
they had a good game last week so I
didn't take anything for granted and we
didn't destroy them we beat them handily
but the place was shaking and I bought
season I was sitting in my series just
showing what the board seats they were
and there you are they and we're at the
50 you know and by the way literally at
the 50 it's not even like I'm looking at
your shot that right down the line your
that's what I'm looking at okay and so
but what I did know was it's not always
gonna be like this like when we play
Tampa Bay at home week four or whatever
right it's not the place is not going to
be shaking but the Bears fans are big
and into it but beating the Packers to
win the NFC Central eliminated se North
I'm an old essential I know yeah I know
that right but and then eliminate the
Packers at the same time that was like
wow only way we could have been better
as if it was the Vikings I hate the
Viking Viking I don't hate the Badgers
I respect the Packers but I don't hate
them I don't like him but I don't hate
him I hate the bike why just that horn
I know just if you know reminds me of
Planet of the Apes like when you first
see the Apes and you're scared yeah I
don't like it it just unsettle yeah I
know you hear that all the time right
yeah now they have it's it's like now
the giallo owners like mmm thank you sir
it sounds more Slingblade never liked
them never liked about that yeah they've
always been the only player I ever liked
on the Vikings mr. Alan page was he a
great Chicago Bear oh yes he was
I loved Alan page mm-hmm I'm just
excited for you man I'm excited too this
is an exciting this is one of the best
football seasons that I ever recall
because almost everybody can win the
Super Bowl
I think even the Eagles who you're
saying rented out would you be shocked
if they made it to the Super Bowl I
wouldn't know I was discussing this the
other day I in the 15 years of me doing
this with the NFL Network I've never
seen a more wide open Super Bowl race
contenders true like it's not like I was
there's a few in the playoffs the stinky
teams know everybody's really good
well I and again in the NFC is a perfect
example of how the one-seed Saints have
beaten the two-seated
Rams the three seeded bears have beaten
the two seated Rams
the fourth seeded Cowboys have beaded
the one seated Saints the Seahawks have
beaten the Cowboys from the five seed to
the four seed in the Rams of beat in the
Seahawks twice they've beaten the
Vikings once I mean the Eagles just beat
the Rams and that's one the most joyful
wonderful season that I've seen in years
I know the energy is totally wide open
as well no it's crazy you know it's it's
delightful
why does Matt Negi wear a visor as a
ball by the way and there's Elfi honest
wear visors and I don't get it I don't
get the visor the visor went out in 1976
tennis
that's who wore visors tennis players
that I don't get the visor and also he's
bald
I mean it's just with its so with the
headset and by the way the Bears have
some classic baseball hats I have one
with the bear
you know the bear I saw it on your
photograph it's black that put that on
Matt Negi so sorry just for the head for
I never forget warmth is skin cancer my
friend there you go he is not although
maybe he'll oceans up before he goes out
you know I'd love to know what L DS
thought would be about the visor in the
bald head oh you would never wear a
visor now on the bald head I love this
thing with the baseball hat like when
you go on dates
you're bald you go on date you meet the
woman with the baseball hat and the
Larry says at some point the Hat has to
come off yeah Jeff Garlin here on the
Richard show okay and then there's our
competition yes very exciting where you
were you were kind of like a do you do
know any good leagues and you said lemme
ask Jerry Cantrell and there was one
spot was a spot left Alice in Chains yes
fantasy football charity League yes now
everybody's out except for the two of us
yes we have the the finale and it's a
pretty even thing if you ask me it was
funny it's so at one point cuz my kids
are constantly looking at the the
rosters and who is available and then
the thing that they love more than
anything else is the computer-generated
prediction prediction yeah and at one
point we had the same exact number one
twenty four point seven or whatever 126
123 oh really close right now
so let's put it up right now touch of
the Vermeil is our team and then your
team needs to be blurred out right now
Louis grandmas but you it's the name of
an animal I'm a big South Carolina
football that's right let's grandmas go
so my kids love the name too which is
great you're very Bears heavy you going
Jeff yeah the reason I did that I want
to just say thing yes first off the only
people that I drafted
we're Tarricone Shuster Bears defense
and for net and no no I never drafted
for net you traded for him I traded for
Fernet and Anne Johnson and I tray and I
picked up too risky off wave in a second
picked up your Biscay off waivers and
you acquired both yeah even Johnson and
I traded away Julio Jones by the way and
Tom Brady and I did it where I went you
see how Bears happy I am and I only did
it so I'd have a good time and then I
thought let me make these bold moves
maybe for a net we'll do something maybe
Johnson will do something there's
certainly high-grade running backs
that's impressive as you won seven in a
row yes because you you know normally
when I draft in fantasy I'm like you
know what I drafted him I'm gonna stick
with him in September that they're gonna
do it and I just think to myself
the minute I trade him they'll start
catching fire and Odell Beckham by the
way was just ruled out for a third
straight week yes morning yes and no
Jones doesn't score touchdowns mmm the
guy catches 150 yards every week right
no touchdown that's not it gives you a
good score but certainly not you know
amazing you nice runs serve
congratulations on the q3 speaking of
trades you're gonna love this bra yeah
you're gonna love this proud manner in
our league yeah there was one particular
person Fabiano Fabiano all right yes I
said do you casually in the dressing
room I said this guy Fabiana he's an
expert at this things NFL Network okay
it's a post expert he offered me we kept
it without week after week day after day
the most insulting horrible terrible
ridiculous trades I could not believe it
like did he think it was playing with
the dumbest people on earth what do we
say when fabs this guy that I'm trying
to tell you despite what the stats look
like he's got
the seventh best tight end ratio against
the PPR 3c players for an a player yeah
but but by the way does he not know that
I don't like him I liked him plenty when
I met him this he was very sick call me
any time we'll talk about it after two
or three of these offers I went I don't
like him he's character he showed who he
is as a man you could jeez no man he is
no man what's worse but getting the
trade offer like that where you feel
insulted
yeah or you make a trade offer that
doesn't even get a response the insulted
the response people have lives and not
fancy footballs now is important to any
people or some people give up whatever
but those are so energy cuz I'm a guy
who likes being on there watching what's
going on you know I don't like that guy
all right of my face we've known each
other too long
equivocally yes
the most dominating team this year in
Harley us you right when you know he
shopped the groceries on the draft night
yeah and then and then I'm the
day-to-day fast waiver wire Kansas City
running back hurt you
well Kareem hunt went down but we picked
up Damian Lewis Damian Williams and he
dominated last week you know you know
I'm just I'm just
Rich Eisen that's what I'm trying to do
one of the most handsome thank you sir a
successful thank you knowledge of all
thank you Jeff go Bonnie thank you
thoughtful
Pirates of the Caribbean Pam no I'm
gonna throw one that was stupid but
you're the greatest thank you right back
do we come back to do the thing no we
can keep going right now
oh we keep going commercial break in the
middle of makes a good automobile you do
like it don't you yeah I don't have it i
I went by for myself I'm rich but the
point being is see what I expect you
expect to get it for nothing no no no no
I'm just saying no I Drive a Lincoln
Navigator new one you and I Drive a
Tesla I have two cars I'm rich all right
so the point being is that no I wouldn't
drive a Honda but guess what my younger
son's getting a car get it what do I win
you want to get him on the court that's
what I want to game straight man yeah
we'll do it a three-year old record
Accord you know the chords are great
cars there's a bit they're fantastic um
do you want to ask asking the poll
question Brockman yeah the poll
questions brought to you by Windy City
rehab it's big risks and big rewards in
the second city is HGTV star alison
victoria renovates property or hometown
of Chicago Illinois I'm not to watch
that show despite the drama roll the
structural damage permit delays and fell
inspections she's determined to create a
gorgeous home against all odds when DC
do rehab premieres January 1st in ears
all Tuesday's after that 9:00 Eastern
8:00 central on e gonna wash attaboy
cause it's from the Windy City and she's
lookin why is it called the Windy City
rich do you know because the wind blows
off oh no in Michigan no politics that's
why it got its nickname cause of all the
talking from the Alderman's all the
talking from the Alderman's all because
of politics that's it is a Windy City
but the politics has nothing to do with
let have nothing to do with without the
air coming off the lake my my my my
coordinating producer Don Bowie sing
back in the day lies were called Wendy's
oh and then that's the Windy City yep
the Chicago Way early vote often
Chicago is like Bo totally bought off
and the Democrats dead
yes when we come back on the air and
December 31st Jeff what's the most
likely thing to have have have happened
I've had happened Oklahoma versus Notre
Dame in the college football
championship uh-huh
the Eagles make the playoffs uh-huh the
Chargers win the AFC West huh the Texans
get a first round bye huh
the Lakers are the number one seed the
chrome the last war--the are currently
fourth or Manny Machado signs with the
Yankees crystal ball at Jeff Garlin
Eagles I'm with him I'm with him Eagles
although I actually think the Eagles
right now are the most dangerous you
don't see them in Soldier Field because
they know how to play in the cold bring
down the Rams to Chicago because that's
all I like the Rams but still all right
evils in the playoffs is 12% right now
okay leading the way the Chargers win
the AFC West 47 percent that means
they're the bots they're the number one
seed by the way if they win the lost
yeah but by the way that could really
happen you know because they were
well-rounded team unlike the Chiefs that
really you know you can't compare the
Chargers defer to the Chiefs defense
there the charges the offense is better
way but I know a Melvin Gordon's coming
back I just don't know that Ravens one
of the two games the Chargers is just
gonna slip gonna kind of wait for the
trap door right then the Chargers is the
charnot's this weekend and then they
tell you everything you need to know I
think it will perform both teams that'll
tell you everything you need to know and
if the Ravens win that game not only do
the Chiefs I think went obviously the
division but if the Ravens win that game
the Steelers could be on the outside
looking into made some silly mistakes
along the way because I think they lose
in winnable game this week they could
slide into that six o'clock all right
because we don't want you to be late for
your table read we're gonna we're gonna
play start bench cut with you before you
go out the door that's right that's my
favorite game
sit down to be quiet all right here we
go
start bench okay start bench cut you got
to start one bench one you got one yes
you recently joined the Los Angeles
Kings announcing booth yes what sport
would you want to call play-by-play for
the most football hockey baseball start
bench cut
Jeff Garlin baseball start okay bench
football cut hockey see love hockey I
must say I don't know enough to visible
because I'm thinking of the fan okay I
could call a good baseball game a really
good baseball game I could call a pretty
good football game
hockey hockey fans they were already
upset that I was in the baby they said
stop your chatting and move on with the
game like these are the tweet tweets
coming you who follow the game the game
is gonna I know so that's why baseball
you could be more lyrical behind the mic
delightful all right can't respect the
fan okay I don't want to run the game
things you hate the most you have to
start the one you hate the most bench
one that's medium and cut the one that
you could you could live with you things
you hate the most getting pitched
stories for curb yes your favorite team
losing in the playoffs yes
ketchup on hot dogs okay hate the most
getting pitched for curb you start that
hate that I tell people don't tell me
I've never used one and we've never used
one but no they tell me because theirs
is gonna be the one never is okay
obviously bench my favorite team being
eliminated in the play okay and then you
know I don't like ketchup on hot dogs
but I would ketchup hungry I'm not gonna
stop me I enjoy ketchup I enjoy how it
dogs
hopefully it's a Vienna beef hot dog and
then you know catch up on it there are
worse things okay Mike your team now
making the playoffs and suck all right
next one team you hate the most
okay good Cardinals Vikings st. Louis
Blues okay this is also very easy
Vikings
the most like start the Vikings bench
the Cardinals and the st. Louis Blues
I love the PLO's not the team the blues
music so I don't hate the Blues because
they're team by the way we called
inaudible when you started railing on
the bike these parents of course bankers
nope and by the way I know a lot other
people in Chicago feel the same as me
hate the Vikings no kidding hate them
hey you're leading the charge right yeah
yeah yeah okay and then you know we've
got two more for you okay I love the
Jeff Garlin start bench press yeah worst
holiday faux pas by the way I also
respect the Cardinals okay dislike more
than the Packers but I I respect you
shoe horn them in-between Vikings and
and pack no you should warn them between
Packers and and blues what you're saying
Vikings Packers Cardinals lose no
Vikings Cardinals Packers look at you
man alright worst holiday faux pas yeah
holiday music being played before
Thanksgiving okay
leaving holiday lights up beyond New
Year's Day right sending holiday cards
after Christmas Day okay start bench cut
Jeff girl starting I would say the
Christmas music before Thanksgiving okay
you don't like that I mean I don't hate
it
okay and then bench the Christmas cards
after Christmas they and then I think
like Christmas light should be on all
year I love them and I think they should
be on 365 days a year kitchen yeah I am
Pro Christmas like any time put them up
at June let's go daddy up at holiday
music being played like around
I don't enjoy I don't hate okay say the
worst I say no the Vikings are the worst
worst holiday Grieg IFFT okay fruitcake
free swag something you made at home
homemade gift okay Oh
so start fruitcake fruitcake even when
it's given in an appropriate or someone
give the origin is just you that's bad
move on the fruitcake period I
just like Christmas lights should be all
year long this I think fruitcake should
be outlawed all year okay okay
and then the something what was the
other free swag or a homemade gift well
a homemade gift I'd been ok because a
homemade gift that's always thought
books using a child ok you know or a
child is your adult ok so it's ok and
then every gifting your swagg always
appropriate do you know what I've done
before
film festivals I'll get my swag bag when
I get there and when the screening of my
movie is I will go and before the show
hand out everything in my swag bag to
the audience so you have done it Oh many
times I give I get by the way I rarely
keep anything from any of my swag bags I
give it to people all the time and you
know and if something's really nice I'm
like Christmas gift it ok you know if
it's really nice I'm saying that's why
you cut it yeah I like it yeah before I
let you go what's the latest on curb are
you still shooting still shooting be
shooting to the middle of March
it'll be on next September October and
as I've told you it's my favorite season
we've done favorite season by far I love
having a blast having truly a blast I
haven't had this much fun on the show in
a long time that just Larry feel the
same way you know what I'm probably you
know what I'm probing for right now I
said another season oh I don't know come
on I don't know but if you're having a
good time while in the middle of this
season we don't work that way you don't
work that way no you just live in life
now I by the way ever many seasons he
wants to do I'm in so am I by the way
yeah thanks pal
times by the way I will get a tweet from
somebody saying that I like appeared on
that one time where I was at your
daughter's Bat Mitzvah you sure I
represented you and John Legend here my
clients other than Larry and Richard
Lewis and I come up and shake your hand
and say Mazel Tov yeah for just a split
second I will get a tweet hey you just
were on curb by the mazelTov
yes my Netflix special that I'm filming
in April what is called Mazel Tov were
you shooting that if I told you you're
gonna go you
kidding me and I'm not the Sportsman's
Lodge here in Los Angeles in the valley
I am shooting my and that looks special
at the sportsmen's lodge it's very
specific special clearly no it is and
that's where I'm actually filming
literally as old as the hill is it's
it's been in front of yeah-yeah
Sportsman's Lodge
Jeff Garlin you're a national treasure
good luck to you this weekend and I
truly do mean that thank you love to
take this land I count us out what do
you mean like we always count yes role
is to break this is Jeff Garlin counting
us to break when we come back your phone
calls news update before brent musburger
Joe you can stay there again five yes do
it four three two one this is the Rich
Eisen show the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience